a dónde van los seguidores de jean-luc
me lesioné en este balotaje teniendo en
cuenta que son un alto porcentaje
exacto eso es un dato interesante porque
no todos los votantes de melo son van a
votar x men por macrón a pesar de que se
pidió que no votaran por la señora lepén
una pequeña encuesta hecha dentro de los
votantes dice que un tercio va votar
polyp en un tercio va por votar por
macrón y un tercio está indeciso o sea
que no va a ser una votación que defina
finalmente el gran apoyo a macro y según
lo que diga puede que se abstengan de
votar
y van a cada uno va a por por su
lado pero si puede haber un gran
porcentaje que
vote en blanco como hicieron otros
candidatos de como la lucha obrera
u2 que ellos llamaron a votar en blanco
ciertos son candidatos que tienen como
8% muy pequeño cierto pero no piden
votar por macro pero tampoco por el epen
entonces va a ser una carrera bastante
cerrada yo creo que ese 54 por el que
ponen ahí por ciento 46 está muy de
fotofinish podemos casi hay que decir
que hay un empate medio técnico en este
momento ahora repite en el balotaje los
mismos candidatos que se enfrentaron en
2017 pero que hay de diferente en estas
elecciones aparte de que la gestión de
macrón ya es conocida por los votantes
bueno
algo que pasó en la vez pasada y que
ahora que fue la caída del partido
socialista en uno de los partidos que ha
siempre ha gobernado esta es la ocasión
para el partido de los republicanos que
es también otro partido que ha estado en
el poder de los partidos de la derecha
de centro cierto que
subió al poder a sarkozy pues es un
partido que acaba de explotar o sea no
logran con
recuperar la plata para pagar o sea no
tienen el 5% de votaciones para que su
campaña sea reembolsada entonces si
efectivamente frente a la campaña
anterior acá hay una implosión de los
partidos tradicionales
también la abstención marca la jornada y
varios franceses están decepcionados de
que se repita las elecciones de 2017
porque no están votando los franceses
bueno también aquí hay una sensación de
desconexión con los candidatos
efectivamente como tú dices no se logra
el porcentaje del 28% abstención del
2002 pero estamos en un 26 por ciento lo
que muestra que es fue la abstención la
que gana frente a
mccann que obtiene el 20 por ciento de
los electores inscritos y el 16 por
ciento lepén entonces si hay una
sensación d
de cansancio